are you ticklish you know it's weird  dude like  depends on who's tickling me yeah  are you ticklish yeah I am are you yeah  think of the coolest person you think  like is future ticklish he might be we  don't know that's a good point imagine  future getting just like tickled in the  armpit just giggling like a stripper  yeah and he's like  if Putin was ticklish that'd be crazy  dude he definitely is man do you think  Putin's taking yeah he's like short and  like us you know so what are you saying  if you're under five nine you're  automatically probably ticklish yeah how  much you weigh right now 210. yeah you  gotta like tickle hard like you know  what I'm saying get around them yeah you  gotta like really get in there yeah it's  like armor against yeah yeah come and  try to tickle me [ __ ] like you  can't good luck yeah